salut à tous ici envergure en plein
marathon médiatique puisque après des
mois d'attentes
nous y sommes la draft nba 2020 est au
coeur de l'actualité ce sera le 18
novembre évidemment vous donne rendez
vous sur faire steam pour la draft en
direct et dès le lendemain pour ceux qui
peuvent pas veiller tard la nuit pour un
ré cas dès l'aube
histoire d'être totalement complet que
personne ne passe à côté de cette draft
qu'on a suivi ça fait quasiment un an et
demi ça fait un an et demi qu'on suit
cette draft et donc ça se passe
également sur notre site
envergure point c'est au vous y trouvez
notre mot graff no big board
les dernières infos drap dont on va
parler là en ce début de podcasts mais
ce podcast là il est consacré un débat
qui aura la meilleure carrière parmi les
joueurs de cette draft débat pas évident
du tout et qui va impliquer d'autres
questions très intéressante et pour cela
nos quatre débatteurs sont la manu belle
nico halal salut les gars ça doit être
tout simplement je ferait office de
pascal praud
c'est à dire que j'animerai en donnant
mon opinion envergure saison 3 épisode
40 a pas pour sa part sain
[Musique]
donc je vous rappelle quand même vite
fait pour écouter ce podcast spotify
deezer youtube podcast a dit google
podcast apple podcast stitcher j'en
oublie plein vous abonnez vous nous
mettez 5 étoiles si vous voulez sinon
vous mettez pas de notes mais au moins
vous vous adonnez comme ça vous allez
vous avez la petite notifs quand il ya
peut-être en verdure qui sort puisque
c'est la nouveauté on est plus mélangées
avec ficelles poster d'un qu'amis match
même si c'est des podcasts on nous
conseille évidemment mais on n'est plus
dans le même fil
donc vous pouvez recevoir les podcasts
que vous voulez parmi les quatre et vous
abonner à ceux ci ceci étant dit avant
le débat on va parler de ces dernières
infos sur la draft et je vais faire
réagir ben tout de suite depuis le
québec qui lie anaïs n'a warka outre
qu'avec deux équipes parmi celles du top
10 alors il y en a certaines qui n'ont
pas voulu le workout y en a d'autres
c'est lui qui a refusé d'y aller
ben est ce que tu trouves ça risque et
oui je trouve sur les skins surtout que
la douche peut-être il pourrait sortir
n'importe où woods n'est pas un
peut-être oui je pense que dans cette
draft ici surtout avec les les retours
pendant sur la tanière briser la belle
au vol il pourrait sortir un couvert il
pourrait y avoir une une récurrence
anthony bennett et avoir une surprise ce
serait pas le résultat le plus le moins
surprenante mais je crois pas que c'est
impossible non plus mais c'est ça il
pourrait être ce qui pourrait amasser à
la fin de la batterie aussi donc c'est
un bon c'est un beau risque qui prend
une belle démonstration de confiance
mais oui je trouve ça vraiment très
risqué à allen
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu penses
aussi du fait qu'il ya des équipes du
top 10 qui refusent de s'intéresser ou
en tout cas qui ne prennent pas la peine
d'aller voir quand il y en a c'est ce
que tu trouves que c'est
dommage puisque les équipes en droit de
visite et 10 joueurs toi tu l'as dans
tes dix meilleurs joueurs
moi je sais ce que tu joues pour saab
être que certaines équipes s'intéressent
pas à killian parce qu'elle serait déjà
du monde à la position pour moi c'est
ses potins cécité en bas de la cuvée bon
peut-être déjà du monde au poste de
maire au poste de devoir activer des
minutes et sur qui tu veux investir mais
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir des
informations déjà sur d'autres joueurs
si ça peut être ça peut être utile à
terme si tu peux si tu peux aller
récupérer de signer ou quelque chose
comme ça plus tard dans sa carrière de
base et ensuite je pense que cleveland
que des équipes comme ça ne s'intéresse
pas à lui ne semble pas s'intéresser à
lui
je trouve ça assez assez dommage disent
que c'est sont pas non plus des normes
garanties sur le poste 2 2 qui des
années après il ya quand même on le voit
dans cet homme dans ce top 10 c'est vrai
deux ou trois spots qui sont vraiment
super propice à aller si les a
identifiés et qu'il a envie d'aller là
bas rhinois il c'est ça c'est ça ça peut
aussi être faire partie de la stratégie
peut être que c'est pas ça du tout même
et ça peut faire partie de sa stratégie
effectivement parmi les équipes qui
envoie beaucoup d'écrans de fumée et
dont on ne sait pas vraiment ce qu'elles
vont faire des trois manu détroit qui
semble s'intéresser à la mélo qui
voudraient trade up est ce que pour toi
ça paraît être une bonne idée pour la
mélo qui apparemment aime bien des trois
aussi selon les informations qu'on a eu
des trois qui va être très actif
visiblement en tout cas essayer de
l'être en amont et le soir de la draft
moi je trouve ça logique parce que c'est
une équipe qui en construction complète
ils ont besoin de talent c'est l'un des
meilleurs talents je pense oui lille
fait partie du top 2 qui est qu'on a
identifié depuis un certain moment donc
temps moi je trouve ça je trouve ça
logique et surtout s'il lui aussi
un petit intérêt pour l'équipe c'est que
ça peu des discussions cohérente et où
il ya eu de la positivité donc je trouve
que c'est intéressant
absolument et donc des trois qui
semblerait vouloir bouger ça peut être
du trade up ça peut être aussi du trech
du tri d'awans c'est-à-dire descendre un
petit peu pourra essayer d'empiler les
les à cette même si ça serait étonnant
que des équipes lâchent leur choix de
draft 2021 qui s'annonce assez
qualitative pour un choix 2020 on n'est
à l'abri de rien évidemment aussi
imaginer d'autres d'autres montages un
peu finances il sur des futurs choix
protéger nico je vais terminer par toi
ce qu'il ya sur notre troisième un fossé
que anthony edwards ne fait pas
l'unanimité ça confirme ce qu'on avait
entendu ailleurs ce qu'on avait pu lire
ici et là sur son background sur son
attitude un peu détendu mais on peut
quand même corriger c'est pas son projet
qui l'a fait descendre c'est à dire
c'est son espèce de voir carlos filmé
sur l'hygiène etc
c'est pas ça même s'il n'y a pas brillé
qui l'a fait descendre parmi les cartes
aujourd'hui
non c'est le sait le travail de fond qui
a été fait toute l'année par les
différents spots nba qui ont permis de
collecter des infos sur sûr qu'il est en
dehors du court ce qui le fait son temps
libre est apparemment voilà il ya déjà
des petits on ne parle pas forcément de
choses incroyables mais y aurait voilà
quelques drapeaux jaunes un yellow flag
par ci par là qui sont que la cote
babès un petit peu après pas c'est le
contraire pour qu'il vienne
les retours que j'ai c'est que les
équipes nba sont apprécié sa maturité
il ya notamment eu quelques quelques
retours là je les ai en direct donc je
les liens en direct du coprah ci est si
c'est trop chaud mais nico lomagne en
apparemment il est aussi catastrophique
en interview avec les avec les
différentes équipes donc là dessus sur
sur la maturité de killian c'était
positif
est ce que disait john olinger deuxième
critique aussi à propos de nicolo man
yonne dans son article paru hier
visiblement qui ne se débrouille pas
très bien l'interview qu'elle s'étend
lui fils de joueurs formatés pour être
plus haut niveau peut-être qu'il a des
attentes un peu trop élevé aussi sur le
rôle qu'ils peuvent toujours est il qu
on y voit très flou et donc pour y voir
encore plus floue qu'on a décidé de
faire un débat et c'est un débat très
intéressant messieurs auquel on va se
coller maintenant qui aura la meilleure
carrière
donc c'est pas qui va être de rester
numéro un c'est pas qui est le meilleur
intrinsèquement même si ça peut faire
partie de la réponse c'est qui
parmi cette cuvée la roja la meilleure
carrière vraiment jouer madame irma vous
pourrez nous ressortir sa dont 4 5 ans
en vous mon camp et on trouvera ça beau
jeu messieurs je vous ai demandé de
réfléchir à la question évidemment en
amont on va commencer par un tour de
table
je vous donne une minute chacun c'est à
dire que j'ai perdu ma montre mais je
vais mettre un chrono je vous donne une
minute chacun pour me dire qui et pour
quoi vraiment en résumé c'est cdu faut
que ça aille vite il faut que ensuite on
puisse rebondir dessus mais c'est le
monde
le coeur de votre propos qui veut
commencer
allez moi je veux bien commencé allez
nico 20 minutes sont partis alors je
vote pour notre ami au congo pour
quelles raisons
et bien parce que il me fait pas il me
fait vraiment penser à bas hamad et
bayod avec un peu plus de talent
offensif et que je me dis que dans la
dans la nba modernes sont son morphotype
son style de jeu sa capacité à pouvoir
switcher sur sur trois postes en défense
ça capte à défendre le cercle son
intelligence tout ça ce cocktail la
faune l'intérieur moderne 3.0 et donc
voilà je me sur sur ça pour que hélas
non pas le titre de numéro un de la
draft mais la meilleure carrière quand
on en reparlera d'ici à 5 6 ans c'est
parfait 53 secondes
j'ai collé la barre est haute messieurs
qui veut prendre la suite après onyeka
au congo l'intérieur de cube ainsi
saverne où la salle ça aux rôles
carolina californie à merci après hong
kong ou qui nous proposez vous allez bel
20 minutes et artistes
j'avais j'avais quelqu'un non sur ma
liste mais je vais vivre moret et
soussigné sur le tech isaac okoro les
araignées
pourquoi parce que simplement c'est un
joueur qu'on ne pourra pas enlever du
plancher sa joie non seulement c'est une
bête défensivement sur l'homme mais
c'est un joueur qui rend ses coéquipiers
meilleurs non seulement puisque
logiquement mais tactiquement sur le
terrain c'est aussi pas quelqu'un qui
qui se quittera s'endort vous voulez ce
à dire qu'il va rester il va faire les
choses qu'il est capable de faire
il va déléguer du côté offensif pour
être capable de maximiser les chances de
son équipe son savoir faire en sorte qui
va se développer vraiment très vite est
vraiment très bien
peu importe la situation dans la calibra
est ce que j'aime beaucoup et le côté la
taxe va suivre je suis convaincu à 100%
que ma taille match et à cocody pour
être arrivé
non parce qu'un procès c'est ça c'est ça
une minute meals économique est parfait
non mes études j'ai tout fait ce que je
voulais absolument isaac okoro donc
mourir pour ses idées
ben tu disait georges brassens à mourir
pour des idées d'accord mais de mort
lente
alan tu veux prendre la suite allez
c'est parti donc vu que j'avais mis au
concours tu peux prendre le même tu as
le droit
j'avais 1 1 à 1 b donc vu que j'avais au
congo et que je savais que je pense que
nico le prendrai que je souscris à tout
ce qu'il a dit je vais prendre la main
lowball l'améliorer parce que je pense
qu'un joueur qui peut initier de l'attak
à haute dose sur pick'n roll s'arrête un
jour forcément mis en avant dans la nba
yens de 2020 ou ce que cette parano les
gens et de diabétiques appelé phénomène
des lieux aux centristes commence de
plus en plus à être présent dans les
équipes avec dont six titres ayant ce
genre de joueurs là je compare pas là
mais logeront par le rôle qu'on va lui
donner
et moi je vois qu'un sceau d'or
supérieure ce rôle là dans cette draft
c'est la meinau peut-être qu'ils gagnent
mais plus là mais le goal de donc je
pense que il va être mis en avant est en
fait beaucoup de jeu de joueurs parlent
d'incertitude moi j'ai beaucoup de
certitudes en fait sur l'âme le beau jeu
c'est ce qui va pouvoir faire quand on
va le mettre sur un terrain il va
pouvoir initier de l'ata qui va pouvoir
très pour les autres et je pense que bon
il ya aujourd'hui ça il sera jamais un
grand shooteur étape il a besoin c'est
rigolo comme jeu pour moi en tout cas
manu manu tu va terminer là dessus tu va
conclure donc avoir la primeur de l'info
la plus fraîche que c'est souvent le 800
billets ce qui prime sociaux diminue
donc maison sports ont été sélectionnés
mais c'est pas grave
j'avais aussi aux coraux comme comme
joueur je pense quoi la meilleure
meilleure carrière parce que
défensivement il est déjà très il sait
déjà tout faire et ça c'est
c'est un point ultra positif dans une
nba moderne qui adore ce genre de
joueurs là tout est dit et je suis
d'accord avec ben je vais suivre un peu
ce qu'il a dit sur le fait que je suis
pas du tout inquiet non plus sur le fait
que c'est dans son attaque il va
l'améliorer sans trop trop de problèmes
malgré des pourcentages notamment c'est
froid assez bas pour un joueur de sa
taille de son gabarit je suis je suis
persuadé dans un cadre nba qui va être
totalement hector être prêt à travailler
a montré au fil des années des progrès
immenses en attaque il va de vérité par
l'un des meilleurs attaquants du monde
mais il va il va limiter la casse et il
va reprendre ma place et c'est à dire
que en tout cas le mieux que ses
camarades de draft parfait manu en
dessous de la minute aussi messieurs
j'aimerais savoir et là vous prenez la
parole qui voulait d'abord comment sur
quels critères on se base pour réfléchir
à une telle question ou si vous y avez
touché un petit peu lors de sept minutes
d'introduction mais mais que sur quels
critères vous basez en fait pour
construire votre argumentation dans
votre tête et ça marche aussi
quand vous faites votre big board c'est
à dire qui vous estimez être le plus
haut potentiel disponible voilà est-ce
que par exemple nico estero content pour
toi c'est le plus haut potentiel aussi à
ça c'est une vraiment une question
difficile
non je pense pas que ce soit le plus
haut potentiel dans le sens où pour moi
le plus haut potentiel c'est williams
quand je le vois je me dis que c'est
celui qui s'est le moins faire deux
choses et pourtant malgré ça patrik
elias et d'hesdin oui c'est déjà un top
ten
donc du coup je pense que c'est lui qui
a la plus grosse marge de progression
moi j'ai établi cinq critères alors je
suis un peu profs sur le sur les bornes
mais un genre très toxique est un mec
net exactement j'ai monté les ouvert
avec les critères donc le un talent le 2
éthique de travail le 3 le fit quatre
marge de progression slash âge parce
qu'on a par exemple hobbit au pinky 1,98
et on à edwards et eyes et compagnie
sont dès 2001
et enfin le cinquième la chance quand le
meilleur exemple pour moi c'est tony
parker hockey du talent de l'éthique de
travail
le fit avec les spurs était bon il ya de
la marge de progression mais si avery
johnson
il faut repas son début de saison va
peut-être que tony parker ne fait pas la
saison qui doit donc du coup le seul
facteur chance ça peut être des
blessures
ça peut être un mec avec qui on s'entend
pas qui va être aidé ça peut être un
assistant coach qui tombe en amour comme
dirait ben avait avec toi et te fais
bosser plus que les autres voilà c'est
je pense que c'est un facteur minime
mais c'est un facteur qui compte les
autres sur les critères est ce que vous
avez un ordre différent c'est à dire un
critère qui serait plus important dans
votre en votre liste
allez-y le fit le site toi + moi toi
l'apôtre du talent si tu le mets plus
bas je mets un peu plus bord je pense
qu'on peut plus boire a surtout dans le
top 5 top 10 parce que alors c'est hyper
important bien sûr c'est créer bien sûr
faut tomber dans le bon endroit au bon
moment mais je crois pas que ça influe
ce que je vois dans un dans un prospect
pourra élire la meilleure carrière moi
c'est georges besse excusez-moi va en
parler est du baath merger parait-il a
fait une année je n'ai jamais si je
pense pas que ça aurait été alors oui ça
aurait été sûrement mieux notre
franchise du top 10 mai et les
situations pas horrible la france
moi je sais c'est juste je rajouterai
1/6 car je suis d'accord avec tous les
critères de dénis co la différence entre
plancher plafond moi je pense que des
joueurs à au plancher et en même temps
au plafond c'est ça qui m'intéresse et
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi la mélo
très bien ben par rama sur le fait que
les knicks soit pas une bonne situation
jeunes ont ils sont clairement pas une
bonne estime pour l'instant
ont ils ont viré tout le monde qui était
avec il avait créé cette situation là
donc je me propose d'espérer pour le
futur le cas ni qu il ya parlé du talent
moi c'est je serai plus profondément que
cinq ans et est ce que est ce que tes
talents sont nécessaires à des écrits
pour ça que j'ai pour ce que j'ai choisi
pour ça que j'ai choisi les accros aux
coraux pour avoir la meilleure carrière
parce que sa défense va être nécessaire
absolument quiconque donc vont optimiser
son potentiel dans à peu près toutes les
situations ce à dire que on aura besoin
de lui pour avoir des stocks puis
limiter l'hémorragie souvent à plat fois
ça va lui donner beaucoup beaucoup de
répétitions puis pour un bonsoir anne
éthique de travail réputée pour être à
la limite du psychotique ses répétitions
alors on se transporte mais un joueur
qui est je crois ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même que vous m'avez tous
citer un numéro un différent de celui de
votre big board à part à la manu qui est
qu'elles sont du coup les autres
critères puisque toi je sais pas comment
tu construis ton big board mais
j'imagine que ces surplus au potentiel
disponible jusqu'à meilleures ventes
moi je veux sur les big band vise le
potentiel je fais selon moi le quel
joueur dans l'est dans les cinq ans dans
les oueds cinq ans à venir soit sur un
vrai bon joueur mais voilà après je suis
je suis d'accord pour moi j'ai
l'habitude si en catégorie g le film
normal les comme une colle retour hors
terrain fois que c'est quand même aussi
important que ce qu'on peut voir sur sur
le terrain et j'attache beaucoup
d'attention à au fait si le joueur
comprend le jeu s'il n'est pas perdu sur
le terrain s'il fait les bonnes choses
au bon non je trouve que ça c'est très
important aussi de comprendre ce qui
fait pas forcément
juste suivre des consignes pour pouvoir
rentrer dans des cases sortent d'une
case instinct ça va avec un talent
kassai hun sen c'est intéressant qui
vous avez jeu si je prends les numéros
un de vos board vous avez quasiment tous
anthony edwards n'a aucun ici qui
croient qu anthony edwards sera la
meilleure carrière de cette draft
pourquoi bébés nés allen nous la mêlée
je crois qu'il n'a pas la meilleure car
ea je crois qu'il va avoir une carrière
un peu à l'image de chant de deuil de sa
personne c'est qu'il va flotter entre
l'excellence et être juste un peu mieux
je sais dans un un positif la plupart
des soi c'est c'est une question de
suite là dedans je pense qu'un minnesota
il la voit pas et non ici c'est de
ramener sa famille reçoivent énormément
responsabilité à l'attaqué pour départ
tout va être gérée par karl
intermittence et et des médias se
procurer ce type là je crois qu'il va
s'y plaire lambin et qui vont de pair si
on regarde les les meilleurs joueurs de
chaque draft qui a eu la meilleure
joueur dans chaque draft la meilleure
carrière
quel est ce que vous arrivez à noter des
points communs entre les meilleurs
joueurs nba à part le talent il
son attaque a dit alan si on regarde
pour moi dans les dernières 2016 et un
petit peu dur à a
c'est un peu de au projet encore la même
chose j'ai encore mais moi je trouve que
c'est les joueurs capables d'initier de
l'attak
c'est en dv franchement et dans une je
souffrais à tout ce qui est dit sur
oguro kong où le problème c'est que ça
sera pour moi jamais un des deux
meilleurs joueurs d'une équipe qui peut
viser le titre
tout simplement ce sera cédée super
troisième joueur de l'équipe qui peuvent
viser le titre mais pas les premières
les deuxième option dans des dans des
systèmes nba qui sont plus en plus basée
sur la taxe sur du jus pick and roll se
retire en sortie de dribble c'est pour
ça que moi je suis je faisais plutôt ces
gens-là tatum en 2017
luca sur 2018 et même triangle même si
encore encore gagné il n'ya pas être
gagner son équipe ni il est quand même à
la base quand il sortait un d'une un des
plus gros pressing offensif thomas
n'diaye donc je peux aussi prêt que veut
baser que sur ça et que ça va le roi du
mans alors du coup qui est ce que
adebayo était dans les deux meilleurs
joueurs de miami pendant les cueillir
ces différents noms évoqué est ce que
anthony davis était dans l'est des
meilleurs joueurs des lakers continuent
de dévisser le meilleur pied vous ceux
des meilleurs pivots il ya aucun joueur
qui quartier digue qu'on peut comparer
anthony des listes sur la décennie 2010
c'est un film complet ok si tu veux mais
je viens de te donner 2 contre exemple
parce que tu vas me dire donc c'est à
dessein yodelice adebayo peut-être
battant tommy davis c'est toujours le
lait le contre exemple qu'on donne tout
le temps à rennes le small ball
finalement ça marche paraît donc tour à
l'est ce qu'elles font et omis des
listes mais ya pas de anthony davis en
fait ballotter par you je suis d'accord
c'est le deuxième meilleur jardinier
mais sur la compagne de plurk là oui tu
as raison
et j'avais déjà les un autre contre
exemple
tant que la meilleure équipe de
l'histoire récente c'est golden state
avec kevin durant mais sans kevin durant
ils ont gagné un titre
nicklas thompson niederbronn green sans
rentrer dans les critères d'initiateur
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais il ya
peut-être le meilleur shooteur à trois
points sorti dribbles de tous les temps
dans cette équipe c'est ça donc moi
j'aurais plus dit quand j'ai réfléchi à
la question j'aurais dit 1-1 ce qu il
alors mam ce qui amène du coup souvent
être l'initiateur mais un une capacité
élite c'est à dire être le meilleur à
quelque chose ça peut être être le
meilleur en drive pénétration comme l'a
été lebron est peut-être qu'il ya encore
sur des années ça peut être être le
meilleur en poule hop comme l'a été le
curry où il a été durant et ça peut être
aussi le meilleur alors que les thompson
il est en concurrence avec kawaii pour
savoir qu'il ya eu la meilleure carrière
des deux pour le moment le parquet rien
n'est pas fini il était dans la même
draft en 2011 et je suis sûr la draft
2010 cela entre john wall il y en a je
vais rajouter c'est de la provocation
entre john wall
derrick favors d'un squeeze hince greg
monroe gordon hayward et paul george qui
a eu la meilleure carrière bonjour je ne
dirais pas le judge aussi le deuxième on
peut dire john wall sinon les
productions non tu pars en partie un peu
loin quand je dis ça démarre en tout cas
si quelqu'un de nouvelles de colas dry
eldritch enrico lundi dan cole aldrich
passe beaucoup trop tard sur twitter
s'est ainsi offert il ya de kansas la
fac préférez vous
pour les anglophones je vous renvoie
vers un super type cobain a écrit n'est
pas sur notre site unique et sur comment
il s'appelle le site n 7 le 7 le plus et
lots sur les knicks très bien partout
sur internet
bon messieurs dans le débat qui aura la
meilleure carrière
on est obligé de parler du coût des
situations qui pourraient faire que
untel ou untel on aura une meilleure
carrière ça c'est intéressant aussi manu
pour okoro que tu as choisi quelle
quelle serait la situation idéale pour
commencer sa carrière même si ça arrive
que plus tard dans les critères ça reste
un des critères 1
parmi les équipes du tu peux faire top
12 parce que je les ai vus en 11-12 ans
qui passera par 11
visiblement chez les spurs même jusqu'à
dire les soit les spurs soit golden
state sont des équipes ultra ultra
cadrés sur hors du terrain condé staff
peut-être parmi les meilleurs de la
ligue
actuellement il par le passé et ce sous
ça va être des équipes qui vont pas
avoir peur de donner des responsabilités
mais aussi de leur dire un pop up
tu vas faire cinq matches sur le banc ou
d'un match engagé et puis on va
t'apprendre un peu ce qu'on nous on veut
que tu fasses on veut que tu t'améliores
le plus et que tu tu vas je pense que
c'est grâce à des équipes comme ça des
organisations comme ça qu'on apprend le
plus et le plus vite
nico qu'est ce que tu voulais dire quand
tu disais le fit en 3 au quatrième
critère chez plus basse et fera la banda
me détester mais je prends l'exemple de
qu'il y en a six qui lie signe signe est
drafté par les knicks tu penses pas
qu'il aura une moins bonne carrière que
s'il est drafté par les pistes inchangé
parler au bout de trois ans et avoir une
super carrière s'il est vraiment si fort
c'est ce que voulait dire à la new wave
mais moi je pense que là on est sur une
gêne sur une draft donc une génération
ou pour moi et peut-être je pense que
alan a raison sur la lame et lobo l'est
peut-être que si on enlève la mélo bol
je vois pas d'autres joueurs capables de
porter une franchise et est en gros dans
cette situation la cité pas capables
s'ils n'étaient pas suffisamment forts
pour devenir de franchise player ou un
joueur très important rapidement ta
capacité à ne m'en dire à ne pas avoir
le deuxième contrat que tu veux à ne pas
avoir la pollution que tu veux aller
quand même beaucoup plus forte et donc
ok s'ils sont bons ils vont faire une
carrière nba
mais s'il arrive
prenons l'exemple de tibi qui n'a s'il
est pas aux knicks
moi je pense que aujourd'hui on n'en
parlerait différemment on en parlait
comme un joueur qui peut exister et
faire une vraie carrière en nba
aujourd'hui peut-être que l'année
prochaine il sera il sera de retour à
strasbourg
donc du coup c'est là où pour moi le fit
et je ne sais pas s'il ya des fans de
community la série parmi vous là mais ça
me fait penser un épisode où il ya un
des acteurs qui s'appelle abed qui en
gros lance le dé à chaque fois que le
des tombes selon le site il ya une une
réalité
comment dire virtuel alternatif pardon
kiedis met en place et pour moi en fait
quand je vois wiseman ows wiseman aux
warriors wiseman hornet wiseman aux
bulls je me dis c'est quatre carrières
différentes qui sauvera lui est donc
peut-être que vous avez raison mais moi
je vois le truc comme ça et donc du coup
à chaque fois quand je vois eyes est
content dit peut être entre 3 et 10 ou
3,15 je me dis il a autant de scénarios
possibles pour sa carrière
ben toi oui aux coraux ou est ce qui
bloque le mieux mon potentiel et c'est
pourquoi tu tu penses à cet endroit là
en particulier
je crois qu'il serait absolument
monstrueux phoenix je crois que sur un
absolument une espèce de godzilla jeu
c'est simple parce que l'attaqué est
vraiment entre les mains de jean becker
était un peu dans les mains de michael
joe si il aurait tout le temps et
l'amour nécessaires pour se développer
il serait surtout il s'est apprécié il
reste 10 minutes pour qu'il est vraiment
à cet instant je crois aussi
là je prêche peut-être pas mal pour ma
paroisse je crois que si je t'aime
thibodeau lui donnerait tous les milieux
dont il a besoin à new york
mais côté shooter une cote sp500 serait
pas témoin idéal
nico à quel point c'est important
d'avoir des minutes tôt dans sa carrière
puisqu'il ya ça aussi si tu tombes dans
un environnement où tu as des minutes
eh bien tu progresses peut-être que du
coup reste plus qu angeli du mine de
rien c'est important dans le sens où on
draft les joueurs de plus en plus tôt et
on peut le voir dans le top ten ya
énormément de joueurs qui sont nés en
2001 et du coup c'est des années où le
développement passe par le jeu alors
bien évidemment on peut se dire on peut
se développer grâce grâce aux
entraînements grâce à un staff
très talentueux mais mine de rien c'est
sur le terrain qu'on va valider toutes
les progressions donc du coup avoir des
minutes c'est l'assurance de continuer à
progresser puisque c'est des joueurs qui
vont être drafté pour finir leur prost
formations vont pas arriver à part aux
beats au pin il n'a pas beaucoup de ceux
dont on parle dans le top-15 qui sont
quasiment des produits finis il ya alan
suite été d'accord avec les critères est
ce que tu tu as pris en compte aussi je
te pose la question toi puisque tu as
choisi la mélo le l'éthique de travail
environnement du joueur et c'est
l'environnement de pas forcément négatif
pour la mélo malgré ce qu'on peut penser
il ya quand même grandi avec quelqu'un
qui vous était un ballon dans la main
qui meilleur mais il ya ce côté et il
est at il envie à titre la grinta pour
gagner ouais ouais c'est bien sûr que ça
doit rentrer en jeu après même si voilà
on essaye de s'informer sur les réseaux
sociaux on essaye de s'informer à comme
mon plan en vrai moi je suis pas
n'hésitez pas dans le vestiaire dit
n'avoir allez je suis pas auprès de là
mais le rôle de pythie depuis en 2020
pour le voir s'entraîner comme shit et
dans le vestiaire d'aucune équipe de
décider blé et auprès d'aucun joueur
donc bien sûr ça doit prendre en compte
mais pour moi c'est quelque chose que
moi je trouve difficilement mesurable
j'ai bien sûr je peut le penser mais j
j'ai pas vraiment de choses auxquelles
me rattacher à part ben oui bien sûr ce
qui sort les bruits et les impôts les
rumeurs et il faut prendre compte mais
c'est vrai que c'est un fait c'est super
compliqué parce que c'était important
c'est que le extérieur l'entourage
l'allemagne celle d'un joueur dans le
fait qu'il par le serveur elle a une
très bonne carrière ndzié même temps je
trouve que c'est difficilement mesurable
parle pas beaucoup
donc c'est compliqué c'est pour ça que
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sortent sur la mélo
d un breton interview que je m'en
foutiste par moments mais j'ai décidé de
de comptes entre trafiquants des idées
dans cette classe de drap delà de 2020
deux il n'y a pas un autre joueur que
j'avais un petit pays avant kong où je
pense que c'est un groupe très très
belle carrière signé mais j'ai décidé
moral de fer avec ce que ce que j'ai vu
sur le terrain
manu qui sont les autres membres de ton
top 3 ta lady okoro tu as qu'il autres
commencent à monter trois cas vécus
savoir si tu devais faire un top 3 des
meilleurs carrière par n'y a pas j'avais
okoro au congo et pas forcément de top 3
de caumont troisième pas forcément un
troisième essai les 2 mai 2002 que je
ouais les de hockey ben oui c'est ce que
doit être un podium oui j'avais cinq
jours j'avais okoro au kangoo cairoli
surtout je crois qu'il peut devenir le
type de joueurs grâce taper un vrai
point par match
tyree ce maxi qui je crois va être
facilitée mais un joueur de championnat
je crois qu'ils atterrissent maxi va se
retrouver avec plusieurs bagues en or
ben non mais je ne dis pas que c'est un
joueur je dis que ça va être super
substitut que tous les équipes avec une
mentalité gagnante vont vouloir
aujourd'hui donc c'est peut-être là ma
carrière me posa de la carrière la plus
couronnée de succès il ya des chances
que ce soit à 8 max le dernier nom que
j'ai dans ma liste c'est un peu la plus
grosse métriques de la brave c'est
alexei pour que celle ci
le truc qui
metric avec complicité qui sait faire
beaucoup de choses
un des trucs qui m'avait millet qui m'a
fait lever des red flag avec dragan
bender les quelques années c'est que la
seule chose comme moyen de lui c'est
qu'ils prenaient des trois points dans
le garbage time là l'église raelienne
beaucoup c'est ce qui a beaucoup joué
cette année et s'est fait beaucoup de
choses il s'échoue t il ses doigts et v
s'est passé il qui est capable de
défendre il a beaucoup joué deux grecs
sont faisait quelques des petits choux
son physique est vraiment un gros point
d'interrogation mais un gars qui s'est
toutefois comme ça s'il prend le le fais
équipe a le port physiquement et billets
sur les micros cachés par les nazis les
gimmicks maintenant avec c'est pour dire
des conneries mais turon par les deux
fils du coup tu vois moi si j'avais été
drafté par une équipe de d2 grecque et
on précise pour ceux qui sont pas eux
qui connaissent pas grand chose au
canada je vois étoiles et ça veut dire
un all star
[Musique]
non c'était ton amour pour lui c'est un
ami qui m'a et qui m'a fait rire parce
que c'est moi je serai juste pas je suis
un énorme fan comme on en a déjà parlé
en d2 presqu'en presqu'en privé mais
voilà ça mais ça m'a fait mal par
exemple si on doit comparer des joueurs
de peut-être des rôles players autres
joueurs de devoir qui je pense vont
avoir une belle carrière
je m'étais mis devine devine vasselle
dix fois avant terre et se maquiller ça
c'est m
justement j'aimerais ça on a vu beaucoup
de nombreuses graves tout le meilleur ou
deuxième meilleur joueur la deuxième
meilleure carrière de la draft
finalement c'est un type qui tombe entre
10 et 20 entre 10 et 30 voire plus loin
si on prend dokic est ce que vous avez
un candidat pour ça enfin ce ne devrait
pas tomber
10 et 20 il devrait tomber dans le top
10 à celle moi c'est le troisième de mon
podium est clairement et je pense qu'il
ya plus de chances qu'il ait une bonne
carrière qu'ils à coco là heureusement
je pars attaqué mes deux compères 1 mais
je vais en ailier du ndi dans cette
draft je pense qu'il aura cas car au
niveau plancher c'est la seule que je
veux c'est pas encore sur quel critère
du coup les mêmes critères fait tu avais
pour le même numéro un ouais non mais
surtout s'il profite en fait on vend si
ici ce qu'on met en avant les accords
aussi la défense de l'asean est un
excellent défenseur
il est juste pas le maire de cet art
pascal couraud 2 par contre c'est un
genre qui a plus de 40 % à 3 points
c'est un plus gros volume que que les
accros pourront maintenant et qu'il ya
des flashes d'initiation d'attaqué de
bouloc oui mais où et vas-y non mais
donc j'ai donc c'est moi c'est moi c'est
le troisième de mon podium c'est au
congo la mêlée au bon goût était une
voix seul segment du 10e au seul
vraiment une carrière de suez n 10 à 18
conforme à se défendre et être le vrai
vrai bon joueur d'équipé tunisiana c'est
très possible
c'est vraiment dans les possibilités la
seule chose qui m'est qui a pour de la
sacem pour moi c'est beaucoup plus
simple oiseau fini qu'un visa kokoro ou
quand on est comme vous je crois que
physiquement surtout séibou biyik en vue
et wave est un témoin gênant 80 je crois
qu'avant et 99 je crois qui physiquement
il est un très bon défenseur mais je
crois qu'il n'y pas pas être
potentiellement le meilleur passeur de
son équipe parce qu'il manque un peu de
viande sur le corps mais oui c'est une
possibilité si en europe comme vraiment
très possible que se soit des versets la
meilleure carrière je dis des bêtises
c'est aaron smith kenyan 99 vassal et
c'est en 2000
du coup manu par exemple si on te fait
dire hors du top-10 sors de ton top 10
un type dont tu pense qu'il peut avoir
une super carrière
j'allais dire à la janis on va pas
comparer son joueur à janis mai mais
voilà un type finalement qui passe sous
les radars et qui a et sur quels
critères de base pour dire ce gars là ça
peut être la surprise
moi mon joueur à la dia nice c'est pire
à lewis
je ne sais pas mcdaniels moi c'est ça je
dis rien ou de si j'attendais jaden
cqeer lewis l'asile vous verrez vous
même ouais parce que ce que tu y as et
le l'un des plus jeunes de la draft il a
deux saisons dans les jambes plein
quasiment avec des flashs offensif assez
incroyable et je pose que juste parce
qu'il n'est pas trop trop dedans en
défense où il a un peu en direct il est
aussi là dans le bon fit l'équipe qui
lui qui sait le cajoler
je pense qu'il peut avoir une très très
bonne carrière de limite de 2 très bon
6e 6 7e homme quoi on peut parle pas de
carrière mali denis tête alors mais un
peu la r1 rolala d'immobilier en fait
quelqu'un qui va être capable comme ça
de de mener une seconde unit mais qui
est au bord d'être titulaire dans une
laiterie club intéressant intéressant à
l'année ce que tu as un candidat
on va pas prendre vasselle vraiment
d'accord le dha forte pâtira lewis - oui
parce qu'il est à mon top 5
maintenant dans mon dernier bande
teasing mais j'irai tyrant and roll
terry wey télé réalité rurale terrible
parce que six mois un mois aux meneurs
de un meilleur de 19 ans qui peut qui
jouent des pick and roll très bon
passeur qui tire en sortie de livres je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui va avoir
des mutants nba est un joueur qui a dans
l'impact wallaby 40 % aux tirs à trois
points sur un bon volume de tir avec du
sortie dribble ricane chrétien mais
malheureusement mais oui je pourrais
mettre une petite cassure sur taille
réelle taille puisque en fait les autres
joueurs qui qui partirent entre 10 et 20
comme je dise si je crois vraiment pour
une carrière je les ai dans mon top 10
ce serait pas vraiment les dirigent
avant on atterrit au board top 10 donc
c'est pour ça
nico et mais est-ce que vous avez des
dark horse comme ça j'entendais patrick
williams a un ego comme ça
ouais mais patrick james dans le top 10
a priori ce sera notre top 10 de la
draft mais c'est pour moi si tu cherches
indianiste c'est à dire le genre de
joueurs où on se pose plein de questions
et qui peut devenir un truc incroyable
vous parliez d'alexei beaucoup c'est ce
qu' il a il a effectivement un plafond
qui à celle ci non parce que il aller
les skis le skills est dingue ward en et
en ayant la taille d'un immeuble
donc forcément ça peut être une grosse
surprise et il est sûr et certain que il
ya tellement de points d'interrogations
autour de lui qui sera pas de raph est
très haut après le deuxième je tiens de
mes chouchous de jeu c'est de le placer
leandro gbagbo lé barreau j'adore le
corps la mentalité le skills est là je
me dis que ça peut être un vrai style
aussi dans dans cette draft et c'est à
ce moment-là peut-être que même le
retour que tu as on
un peu plus d'importance le côté
attitude et c'est que le talent quand on
descend dans la raf pour chercher la
pépite la fameuse phrase là le
talentueux et battu par le travailleur
si le talent tu ne travailles pas dur
moment mon boulot au quotidien c'est
justement d'enquêter sur sur les intel
donc sur les infos en loin du terrain
entre guillemets un ce qu ils font
comment il s'entraîne avec qui sortent
ce qu'ils boivent et c est sûr prokofiev
qui l'histoire elle est assez incroyable
et je pense que si le corps tient bon
façon au plus bas on aura un white
baseball est au plus haut on aura
quelques lignes d'arrivée exceptionnels
et sur ball marot pareil c'est un
argentin donc c'est un mec à la dalle
qui va défendre comme si sa mère avait
été insulté par le joueur adverse et qui
a des qualités
bien sûr il s'agit a pas que ce à quoi
s'énerver si ton fric candidats pour
terminer le candidat un conte eu une
réponse vraiment très banales mais je le
vois comme le décrivait septième homme
qui est capable d'un peu tout faire et
de mener une seconde unité et aussi de
s'intéresser red line up des semaines et
des semaines un produit fini mais je
pense j'aime beaucoup la comparaison que
parce que il a deux skieuses qui vont
être immédiatement applicables à la vie
mais moi je n'aime pas les comparaisons
mais cette comparaison je n'adore au
plus me l'enlever de la tête pendant que
le fils c'est fou je pense que j'aurai
choisi patrick williams en plus un pur
pour tenter de faire l'original
et que en surprises je pense que
j'aurais pris chez hampton qui pourrait
être dans le top 10 mais un jam tonnes
s'il travaille bien voilà on passa les
gars on parle beaucoup on rit beaucoup
de pâques où ses fils qui joue en
deuxième division grecque mais à janis
joie deuxième division grecque où steve
c'est pas rien car mur ouest
c'est pour ça que je faisais le lien
mais voilà est ce que vous avez envie de
citer un type qui est qu'il vous plaît à
bondir sur une rumeur que vous allez
entendu avant qu on termine cette
émission j'aime beaucoup il aidé la
théorie l'idée sur papier de imad lahoud
quickly paris miami
rené flotte dans sa direction mais je
crois que s'il ya un endroit où est-ce
qu'ils pourraient devenir plus que ce
que je vois raisonnement lui c'est la
baule électorale m ce serait extrêmement
problématique pour les équipes de l'est
c'est si il arrive on faire spécialiste
du tir parce que pour moi c'est pas plus
que ça je pense bien aimé spécialiste du
tir comment la rumeur que j'aime que je
dis m'intéresse c'est est-ce que boston
vraiment monté avec atlanta pour aller
chercher au congo ça sort de partout
elle s'intéresse par intérêt aussi
directement mais elle pourrait être
extrêmement intéressante jeu trop
personnel absolue moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
de bruit mais j'aurais juste rebondir je
comprends pas le topping bashing donc si
vous pouvez me l'expliquer en deux
minutes là je vois tous les fans de
toutes les équipes défoncé hobbit opine
non pas qu une autre minute s'il vous
plaît est ce qu'il ya une grande
majorité ce qu'ils défendent pas je suis
à l'étranger je le résume et je le
résume comme match nice là où jim
o'neill a résumé maintenant
anthony edwards défend pas non plus à
perdre et un intérieur cosy et edward
sont la loi on a vu qu'ils pouvaient le
faire
lobito pinon a peur qu'ils ne puissent
pas me faire c'est ça la différence
c'est à dire que il ya là il apprend
d'abord aux beatles à chercher ses
enfants à l'école savourer les images
les images de ces dates de sa défense
sur pick'n roll les enquêtes le rouge on
sait mais moi aussi je trouve qu'on est
trop dur parce que un type qui peut être
ou qu'il faisait lire forcément tu peux
en faire quelque chose dans un effectif
qui gagne c'est moins dur avec john
collins mais john collins il peut pas
défendre contre une chaise bien sûr mais
c'est la comparaison idéal john collins
qu'est ce que tu veux tu es ce que tu
peux avoir john coyle dans son équipe
pour les devants aux pleurs je suis
passion non moi je préfère te prendre
toi que john collins ça c'est sûr et
certain
tu vas pas vu jouer au basket alors même
en fait c'est tellement insupportable
d'avoir un joueur comme ça où tu dis il
joue au handball
il a envie de s'asseoir sur le banc à
chaque fois son équipe défend c'est un
support mais mais effectivement il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui pensent ça ça
a été résumée par jonathan gigogne chésa
claude conseille quand même d'écouter
parce qu'il ya pas mal d'informations de
est d'avis très éclairés notamment deux
matches litzman chose qui est là si dur
que ça avait que huit piles et qui dit
attention un joueur qui sait lire le jeu
aussi bien que ça en attaque va
forcément faire des lectures
intéressantes en défense en tout cas le
cerveau faire des rotations correct
défensivement
donc je pense aussi que les gens sont
très durs avec lui je comme je le dis
souvent à quelque peu comme un fait
grave
l'effet play-offs correspond plus le
joueur
certaines équipes dont les knicks on
devrait s'en [ __ ] éperdument politique
on devrait s'en foutent éperdument un
joueur comme hobbit au piège comme
cleveland ou new york à se sortir du
trou d'abord et avant tout absolument il
contient deux joueurs qui intéressent
puisqu'il n'ya pas que cleveland qui a
work out by taupe il ya au fond -
chicago golden state et et charlotte
simpson je peux confirmer que new york
la world cup voir new york quand il ya
autant d' équipe du top 10 c'est pas que
des frontoffice de lumière mais ça veut
dire qu'il ya énormément ce cas août qui
sont intéressés ils ont que dix choix
pour workout ça veut dire quelque chose
ça veut dire qu'il ya un consensus sur
le fait que le gars peut être utile et
ben moi je prends je prends les paris 1
je suis je monte je suis seul pour
l'instant dans le train mais j'adore ce
joueur est une blague on tue la patiente
est augmentée de 3 ouest c'est vrai à
l'âne joua depuis le début de la saison
je j'aime beaucoup
après effectivement c'est peut-être le
seul joueur qui défend pas que j'aime je
sais pas pourquoi mais c'est que je vois
de lui en attaque me fait parfois
oublier que que lui aussi en défense
c'est pas trop son truc un peu comme la
meinau avec alan messieurs je vous
remercie et on se dit on se donne rendez
vous très vite on va refaire un poste
est quand même juste avant peut-être
sortira un jour ou deux avant la draft
pour parler vraiment des dernières infos
slash rumeurs sache ce rapport extérieur
on a pu entendre ou lire ici et là
réagir à tout ça on vous retrouve
évidemment on le redit que celle
affaires steam sur twitch en direct le
soir de la draft ont sur nous pour être
avec nous et un d'ici là vous avez tous
les cas outin rapport disponible sur le
site envergure coincé au c'est un régal
salut tout le monde chap